you've gotta be bold in life you've got
to take life on now here's something
else you must be positive because see
when you know within yourself things are
going to work out for you when you know
within yourself that someway somehow
you're going to make it and this is just
some of these are just some of the hoops
you've got to flip through in order to
get there it's okay
if you want to reach your goal and have
a competitive edge you've got to be
hungry
visualizing myself being a disc jockey I
saw myself on there
so one of the things in order to make
this year a decade in order to reach
your goals you've got to find some
reasons that make you strong some
reasons that will make you hang in there
with times get rough because they're
going to get rough
but in the down moments that's when you
discover who you are when you wake up in
the morning look at your goals your
goals will tell you what time you get up
in this plasma scram you put in your
pocket and the main touch you put it in
your heart